.
(Frau) Links geht es runter,
aber ...
Wenn ich als blinde Person
Bergsteigen gehen will,
weil ich das so gern mache, habe ich
wenig Verständnis, wenn es heisst:
"Das ist zu schwierig,
das geht nicht."
(Mann) Links ist ein Spalt.
Mach einen grösseren Schritt
direkt zu mir hoch.
Laila Grillo ist blind
und lebt ihren Traum vom Klettern,
der sie diesen Sommer bis auf 4'000 m
aufs Allalinhorn bringen soll.
Hier vor dir.
Ein Ziel,
das sie aber nur im Team schafft -
ein Team, das sich gegenseitig
blind vertrauen muss.
* Epische Musik *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich bin hier
für die Gäste von Tisch 22.
(Frau) Ja, das sind wir.
- Guten Abend miteinander.
(Frauen) Guten Abend.
- Mein Name ist Laila.
Wir machen zuerst eine Polonaise
und gehen in den Halbdunkel-Gang.
Dann gebe ich Ihnen
ein paar Informationen zum Raum.
Ist das okay?
- Ja.
Jetzt können Sie bei mir andocken.
Genau.
Achtung, Service.
Doch was bedeutet es,
blind zu sein, im Dunkeln zu leben?
Dies ist Ihr Stuhl.
- Danke.- Bitte schön.
Ich lasse Sie kurz ankommen
und komme gleich wieder.
Ist das okay?
- Ja, danke.
Dies vermittelt
Laila Grillo ihren Gästen
im völlig abgedunkelten Restaurant
blindekuh.
Service.
Ich finde es total spannend,
den Gästen
im Dunkeln etwas zu zeigen,
was sie sonst nicht erleben können.
Ich finde
auch die Gastronomie total toll,
weil man den Gästen ein
sensorisches Erlebnis bieten kann.
Achtung, Service.
- Yes.
* Rumpeln *
Heiss?
(Mann) Ja.
- Oh, là, là.
So, Ladys.
- Ja?
Als Aushilfe bewirtet sie
im Dunkeln ihre sehenden Gäste,
um ihnen ein Gefühl zu geben,
was es heisst, nichts zu sehen.
Danke schön.
-Ich wünsche Ihnen guten Appetit.
Vielen Dank.
- Gern geschehen.
Hier sind die Sehenden
die Menschen mit Beeinträchtigung.
Achtung, Service.
So. Ich glaube,
ich habe sogar die Kurve erwischt.
Ich finde es schön,
dass man die Dunkelheit,
auch in Bezug auf die Sensorik,
anders wahrnimmt.
Man muss z.B. mit der Zunge, mit der
Nase oder mit der Hand herausfinden,
was im Teller ist.
Wir dürfen uns
auch auf diese Sinne verlassen.
Service.
Alltag bedeutet für Laila das,
was für Sehende nicht alltäglich ist.
Hier ist sie auf Hilfe angewiesen.
So auch beim Klettern.
D.h., sie gingen nicht. Das ist gut.
Warte,
ich stecke noch das Mikrofon ein.
Warte, sag mir, welche Seite.
Auf Hilfe eines Headsets
und ihrer Freundin Delia,
die ihr per Funk
Anweisungen in der Wand geben wird,
wo und wie sie klettern soll.
Hallo, hallo.
- Ah, jetzt. Jetzt.
Uh.
- Super.- Das ist laut.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Seit sie fünf Jahre alt ist,
ist Laila vollblind.
Ich hatte eine Netzhautablösung
und mein Sehvermögen
ist daher gleich null.
Ähm ...
Ich habe aber noch
eine Hell-Dunkel-Wahrnehmung.
Das kann man
folgendermassen beschreiben:
Wenn man die Augen schliesst
und die Hand vor die Augen hält,
merkt man ja, dass
etwas Dunkleres vor den Augen ist.
Ja.
- Dann bemerkt man einen Fleck.
Ich nenne das einen Fleck.
Okay, es ist
auch ziemlich gradlinig.
Einer links,
einer rechts, einer links,
rechts ein grosser
und hier sind Elemente.
Dann kommt bereits der Überhang.
Laila und Delia
kennen sich seit ihrer Kindheit.
Sie gingen gemeinsam
in die Sekundarschule
und begannen damals mit Klettern.
Bin ich deine Augen, Laila?
Vielleicht kann man das
zu einem gewissen Grad so sagen.
Ich sehe es und kann versuchen,
ihr zu vermitteln, was ich sehe.
Sie hat manchmal
ihre ganz eigene Art und Weise,
mit der sie spürt, wo es langgeht.
Der Tastsinn
spielt eine ganz grosse Rolle.
Dieser ist nicht nur
auf die Hände beschränkt.
Man sieht an der Wand
auch mit den Füssen
bzw. eigentlich
mit dem ganzen Körper.
Der Ellbogen spürt etwas und
sendet eine Information ans Gehirn:
"Oh, beim Ellbogen,
beim Knie oder in Hüfthöhe ist was."
Es sind v.a. der Tastsinn
und das Gehör, die aktiviert werden.
Links noch etwas nach oben.
Nein, geh nochmals etwas runter.
Auf 12 Uhr ist einer für links
und einer für rechts.
Ja, genau. Direkt daneben
ist noch einer. Den Fuss runter.
Das Gehör
schaut sich irgendwie auch um.
Man hört, wenn ein Überhang kommt
oder wenn links oder rechts
ein riesiges Element ist.
Auf 12 Uhr sind zwei, gerade
über dir und unter dem Element.
Auf Kniehöhe kannst du stehen,
super.
Schön.
Gerade über dir ist der letzte.
Super.
* Sie jubelt. *
- Drei ...
... zwei, eins ...
... Boden.
Yes. Gut gemacht. Total gut.
Wenn Delia total nervös wäre,
würde sich das sofort übertragen.
Aber wenn sie
die Anweisungen ganz ruhig gibt
und total bei sich ist ...
"Entspann dich mal,
lockere dich, mach mal eine Pause."
Ja, dann ...
Dann überträgt sich
das irgendwie auf mich.
Der mentale Aspekt ist
beim Klettern total wichtig.- Ja.
Rechts etwas tiefer.
Klettern in der Halle ist für Laila
Sport und Herausforderung zugleich.
Sie ist als einzige sehbehinderte
Frau neu im Swiss-Para-Climbing-Team,
dem Nationalteam für Kletterer/-innen
mit Beeinträchtigung.
Ihre grosse Passion ist inzwischen
auch das Klettern in der Natur.
Man hat irgendwie ...
Draussen nimmt man mehr wahr.
Einerseits
gibt einem der Wind eine Info,
manchmal hört man Kuhglocken,
einen Bach,
oder man nimmt einen Geruch wahr.
Dann denkt man sich: "Hier riecht es
so und auf dem Gletscher anders."
Man nimmt
eine bunte Palette an Dingen wahr,
die zusammen mit dem Klettern
einen Blumenstrauss an Erlebnissen
bieten.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Laila sieht mit ihren Sinnen,
was Sehende nicht mehr sehen.
Ah, schön. Es ist ganz ruhig.
Als Vorbereitung für
den Viertausender, das Allalinhorn,
ist sie heute mit Freundin Delia
und dem Bergführer Ralf Weber
auf einer Testtour
im Berner Oberland unterwegs.
Nun kommt
in Brusthöhe ein Drehkreuz.
Was hallt hier so?
Ist das die Felswand?
Ja, das ist die Felswand.
- Hier könntest du klettern.
Huhu!
* Ein Nachhall ist zu hören. *
Wow. Das klingt fast wie eine Höhle.
Die Wand ist etwa ...
... 40 m hoch.
Wo beginnt der Überhang?
Er beginnt schon relativ weit unten.
* Er lacht. *
Es ist schon ziemlich steil.
- Ja, es ist alles steil.
Oh, ja, das ist schön.
* Tastgeräusche mit dem Stock *
Oh, wow.
Schön.
Möchtest du übernehmen?
- Ja. Ich brauche keinen Stock.
Du brauchst keinen?
- Nein.
Hältst du dich am Rucksack fest?
- Mhm.
Weiter geht's.
- Warte, ja, ich habe dich.
Hast du etwas Gutes gefunden?
- Ja.
Auch hier ist sie auf die Augen und
v.a. die Worte anderer angewiesen.
In diesem Fall ist es neben Delia
der Bergführer Ralf Weber,
mit dem sie seit einigen Jahren im
Winter in den Bergen unterwegs ist,
den sie gut kennt
und dem sie vertraut.
Jetzt wird es etwas abschüssig,
sodass
du nicht mehr stecken bleibst.
Wenn ich mit Menschen unterwegs bin,
die eine Beeinträchtigung haben,
ist es für mich am wichtigsten,
dass die Beeinträchtigung anfangs
nicht zu viel Gewicht erhält.
Der Prozess ist immer derselbe:
Man muss herausfinden,
welche Bedürfnisse, welche Wünsche
und wie viel Erfahrung
die Leute haben.
Jemand, der nichts sieht
und viel Erfahrung hat,
fühlt sich am Berg
deutlich wohler als jemand,
der keine Erfahrung hat
und alles sieht.
Erst am Ende zeigt sich, wo
zusätzliche Unterstützung nötig ist.
Wo benötigt Laila, die nichts sieht,
mehr Unterstützung als jemand,
der etwas sieht?
Das kann ich nicht wissen,
das weiss sie am besten.
Das funktioniert später im Dialog.
Hier
ist eine kleine rutschige Stelle.
Hältst du dich noch fest?
- Ja.
Ja, das ist okay, jawohl.
Links ist eine Wand.
Ralf hat viel Erfahrung
mit Menschen mit Beeinträchtigung.
Delia kann vielleicht
die Tritte ankündigen.
Bis jetzt geht es.
Ja.
- Tipptopp.
Jetzt kannst du dich
am Rucksack festhalten.
Bereits als Jugendlicher
begann er mit jungen Menschen
mit Handicap zu klettern.
Diese Erfahrung
bereicherte ihn so stark,
dass er später beschloss,
Bergführer zu werden.
* Lachen *
Heute ist er
in seiner Tätigkeit als Bergführer
zu rund 40 %
mit Menschen mit Beeinträchtigung
in den Bergen unterwegs.
Ja, gut, tipptopp.
Heute will er herausfinden,
wo Stärken und Schwächen
von Laila liegen
und wie Laila und Delia
zusammen funktionieren.
Wenn man geradeaus nach vorn schaut,
würde man den Grat sehen,
der aufs Gällihorn führt.
Auf dem Wegweiser steht:
"Gällihorn - 20 Min."- Ah.
Was manchmal auch hilft,
ist eine Zeitangabe.
Wenn du sagst: "In 5, 10
oder 30 Min. sind wir dort",
hilft mir das,
meine Energie einzuteilen.
Ich weiss zwar nicht,
wie der Weg in den nächsten 10 Min.
sein wird, aber ...
Dann versuche ich
das mit der Zeitangabe:
Wir haben noch 15 Min.
auf einem guten Weg vor uns.
Aber er wird wieder grüner.
Es wird mehr Tritte geben
und etwas rutschiger werden.
Noch eine?
- Ja.
Du kannst noch einen Schritt
geradeaus machen.
Ziel ist das Gällihorn,
2'282 m ü.M. im Kandertal.
Jetzt kannst du dich
nach rechts orientieren.
Danach kannst du dich
an der Wand festhalten. Genau.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Ralf hat eine Tour ausgesucht,
die viele Komponenten
des Bergsteigens beinhaltet,
die auch am Allalinhorn
gefordert sind.
Noch etwas weiter hoch. Yes.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Dazu gehört
eine steile Kletterpassage,
die Laila bewältigen muss.
Hält es? Bist du stabil?
- Ja, jetzt schon.
Gut, jetzt geht es
in diesem Schlitz nach oben.
Du bist in einem Kamin. Du kannst
vor dir in die Mitte greifen.
Ja, genau.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Den musst du überwinden.
Ralf sichert vorne,
Delia gibt unten Anweisungen.
Ja, dort.
- Hier?- Ja.
Etwas mehr links,
dort ist eine flache Stelle.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Jawohl, dort ist es gut.
Super.
Runter, runter.
Total runter, dort ist der Boden.
Jetzt kannst du nochmals rechts ...
Das Zusammenspiel zwischen Laila
und Delia funktioniert auch am Fels.
Achtung, dein Kopf.
Ja, hier ist der Helm sehr nützlich.
- Ja.
Und die Sonne ist wieder da.
Es klappte gut mit dem Klettern,
nicht wahr?- Ja.
Nach 4 Std. erreichen sie
den Gipfel des Gällihorns,
hinter sich Anstieg
und Kletterpassage.
Jetzt kannst du nach vorn kommen.
Spürst du es?
- Hier oben beim Querbalken.
Die Pünktchen über dem Ä
liegen seitlich.
Ah, ein Ä.
- Jetzt kommt das L.
...LLI...
An zwei Stellen war ich mir
unsicher, ob Laila hochkommt.
Aber letztlich
schaffte sie es eleganter als ich.
Es sind andere Stellen, die ...
Ich glaube,
v.a. Stellen im einfachen Gelände,
wo du dich nicht festhalten kannst,
sind schwierig für dich.
Es ist eigentlich
nicht wirklich anders,
wenn man
auf allen Vieren klettern kann.
Dort, wo es offen ist
und wo ich aufrecht stehe,
auf einem Plateau oder so,
traue ich mich fast nicht
oder kaum zu bewegen,
weil ich nicht weiss,
wie rasch es steil runtergeht.
Laila musste einen steinigen Weg
gehen, um auf die Gipfel zu kommen.
Zu Beginn wurde sie wegen ihrer
Blindheit teilweise zurückgewiesen,
weil Sehende ihr nicht zutrauten,
als Nichtsehende
in einer Gruppe mithalten zu können.
Es gab Zeiten,
in denen ich genervt war.
Am Anfang dachte ich:
"Bergsteigen ist ein Traum,
den ich mir erfüllen möchte."
Dann hiess es: "Nein, das
geht nicht, das ist zu schwierig."
"Das können wir uns
nicht vorstellen."
Da drehte ich schon etwas am Rad
und fragte mich, was ich tun soll.
Wie soll ich argumentieren?
Aber wir haben Lösungen gefunden.
Das ist gut.
Du kannst dich mit einer Hand
festhalten, wenn du willst.
Nun folgt ein langer, steiler Grat.
Jetzt
ist es stark nach links exponiert.
Hier zeigt sich
Lailas Handicap stärker.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Hier geht es senkrecht runter.
* Pfeifen des Windes *
Ja.
Jetzt geht es runter.
Du musst mich kurz loslassen.
Jawohl. Zurzeit bist du
über den Zacken gesichert.
Laila hat keine Referenz,
links und rechts keinen Halt.
Nun nehme ich das Seil
aus dem Zacken raus.
Du stehst gut, nicht wahr?
Jetzt gehst du am Fels entlang.
Dort stehst du gut.
Okay.- Dort ist es griffig.
Jetzt musst du dich
mit beiden Händen
kurz an meinem Rucksack festhalten.
Schritt für Schritt,
in völliger Dunkelheit,
einzig angewiesen auf ihre Sinne und
die Anweisungen von Ralf und Delia.
Etwas mehr nach links.
Dort ist wieder ein Fels.
Solche Passagen sind für Laila
eine doppelte Herausforderung.
Jetzt bist du gleich auf dem Grat,
wo du dich nicht festhalten kannst.
Du kannst
ein bisschen runtersteigen.
Sie ermüden sie nicht nur körperlich,
sondern v.a. auch mental,
da sie all die Informationen
und Sinneseindrücke
im Dunkeln verarbeiten muss,
um sicher voranzukommen.
So ...
In solchem Gelände
ist man extrem langsam.
Ja, hier sind wir
langsamer als beim Klettern.
Für uns ist das ja nicht schwierig.
- Genau.
Der kommende Teil
ist aber schwieriger.
Vielleicht sind wir nicht langsamer.
- Nicht langsamer?
Ja, weil du mehr beide Hände
benutzen kannst.- Aha.
Wenn ich rasch entscheide
und gute Entscheidungen treffe,
kann ich hier
ziemlich viel Zeit gewinnen.
Im einfacheren Gelände
eigentlich nicht.
Wir müssen einfach irgendwie durch.
Es gibt gewisse Schlüsselstellen.
- Ja.
Sobald solches Gelände kommt,
bin ich extrem langsam.
Ja.
- Anders geht es nicht.
Ralf weiss nun,
dass Kletterpassagen für Laila
leichter zu bewältigen sind,
da sie Hände und Füsse
einsetzen kann.
* Dröhnende, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Im Gegensatz zu scheinbar leichten
Passagen, wo sie keine Referenz hat.
Links auf Kniehöhe
kannst du auftreten.
Dort ist wieder ein Plateau.
So wachsen die drei an diesem Tag zu
einem Team zusammen, das bereit ist,
das grosse Ziel, das Allalinhorn,
in Angriff zu nehmen.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge,
Raubvogelruf *
* Muhen *
Eine Pfütze.
Laila arbeitet seit Kurzem in der
Administration auf dem Birsmattehof,
einer landwirtschaftlichen Genossen-
schaft für biologischen Landbau.
Es war für sie eine Erlösung,
als sie diese Stelle bekommen hat.
Dort muss ich noch etwas eintragen.
Excel funktionierte nicht.
Ich mache das
in den nächsten 30 Min.
Das ist auch für morgen.
- Dann schaue ich, wer das macht.
Mehr als ein Jahr lang
hat sie Arbeit gesucht
und wurde immer wieder abgewiesen,
bevor es hier klappte.
Zuerst konnte ich es nicht glauben.
Ich freute mich total und dachte:
"Nein! Wirklich?"
Es ist
eine totale Erleichterung und cool.
Wie im Klettern
muss sie auch im täglichen Leben
gegen Vorurteile ankämpfen.
Danke Ihnen. Auf Wiederhören, danke.
Ich war oft traurig
und ziemlich wütend,
wenn ich Absagen kriegte,
in denen stand:
"Wenn Formatierungen
nicht möglich sind,
können wir Sie nicht einstellen."
Daran sollte es nicht scheitern.
Man wird ja wegen seiner Kompetenzen
eingestellt und nicht,
weil man ein Dokument
formatieren kann.
Für solche Dinge
gibt es eine Assistenz.
Man kann
eine Arbeitsassistenz einstellen,
was von der IV bezahlt wird.
Dann braucht man nicht ...
Der Betrieb
bezahlt die Assistenz ja nicht
und ich kann sie
die Dokumente formatieren lassen.
(Mann) Tschau-tschau.
- Tschüss.
Grüss Daniel.
- Mache ich.
Sich immer wieder neu orientieren
und neue Wege suchen,
gehört zu ihrem Leben.
* Fahrgeräusch des Velos *
Ähm ...
Fährt das Velo vorbei?
Seit 27 Jahren geht Laila
als vollblinde Person durchs Leben.
Bis im Alter von fünf Jahren
hatte sie noch einen Sehrest von 5 %.
Laila kam zu früh auf die Welt.
Die damit verbundenen Komplikationen
führten zu dieser Beeinträchtigung.
Mit fünf Jahren
kam es zu einer Netzhautablösung
und eine Operation wurde nötig.
Dann fand die Operation statt
und als ich aufwachte,
musste mir meine Mutter beibringen,
dass ich nichts mehr sehen würde.
Das war schon ...
Für meine Eltern war das heftig
und für mich auch.
Mir zu erklären, dass es nicht
mehr besser wird und so bleibt,
war schon hart für sie.
Es gab Phasen,
in denen es mir nicht so gut ging,
in denen ich traurig oder wütend war
und mich fragte: "Warum?".
Ja.
Laila musste früh lernen,
ihren eigenen Weg zu gehen.
Seit einem Jahr
hat sie eine eigene Wohnung.
Vorher hat sie
in Wohngemeinschaften gelebt.
Grüezi.
- Hallo.
Und seit drei Jahren
ihren ersten festen Freund: Daniel.
Kennengelernt haben sie sich
in einem Tanzprojekt
für sehbehinderte Laien.
Ich glaube, ich habe
noch nie einen Menschen getroffen,
der so aktiv ist
und sich so rasch
von Dingen begeistern lässt.
Ich hatte schon Beziehungen
zu sehenden Frauen,
und das ist schon etwas anderes.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
dass es entspannter ist,
mit einem Menschen zusammen zu sein,
der auch eine Sehbehinderung hat.
Dank Laila
hat Daniel mit Wandern begonnen,
doch bei Bergtouren
bleibt er zu Hause.
Ich mache mir Sorgen,
wenn sie Hochtouren macht,
die ja gefährlich sein können,
z.B. bei einem
plötzlichen Wetterumschwung.
Man hört so viele Horrorgeschichten.
Dann habe ich schon Schiss
bzw. mache mir schon Sorgen.
Aber ich habe gelernt,
irgendwie damit umzugehen.
Wie ich hörte, macht sich
deine Familie auch Sorgen.
Ja, ja.
- Und, ähm ...
Sie zieht es durch. Aber das ist
wichtig, es ist ihre Leidenschaft.
Dann haben wir einander
etwas zu erzählen.- Ja.
Sie macht Ihres und
ich mache Meines. Das ist wichtig.
Cheers.
- Chin-chin.
In zwei Tagen geht es los.
Dort, wo wir starten,
ist ja nichts Grünes mehr.
Dort sind nur noch schroffer Fels
und Eis.
Zudem ist es ein Grat.
Das habe ich
noch nicht so oft gemacht.
Daher bin ich total gespannt
und freue mich darauf.
Wirklich lecker.
- Lecker?
Es ist Ende Juli.
Laila, Ralf und Delia sind unterwegs
zur Britannia-Hütte auf 3'030 m,
wo sie die Nacht
vor der Tour verbringen werden.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Die Bedingungen sind gut,
doch für den morgigen Tag ist
eine Schlechtwetterfront angekündigt.
Ihr Ziel,
das Allalinhorn auf 4'027 m,
ist von der Hütte aus
noch nicht zu sehen.
Die Route
führt sie morgen über Geröll,
Gletscher
und über den Hohlaubgrat zum Gipfel.
Ralf rekognosziert noch am Abend
den ersten Teil der Strecke,
den sie morgen
im Dunkeln bewältigen müssen.
Hier ist ein Regal voller Schuhe.
Du bist beim Regal
auf der linken Seite.
Derweil orientieren sich
Laila und Delia in der Hütte.
Rundherum sind Regale
und in der Mitte Bänke.
Denn morgen geht es früh los.
Das hier. Soll ich mich
auch hierhinsetzen?- Ja.
Wir gehen morgens hier runter.
Es sind knapp 150 Höhenmeter.
Danach
kommt ein total blöder Abschnitt.
Der Gletscher
ist extrem zurückgegangen
und es gibt viel Blockgelände.
Dort müssen wir
ganz vorsichtig sein.
Danach erreichen wir den Gletscher.
Bis dorthin benötigte ich
allein 10 Min.- What?
Ich glaube, wir müssen
mit locker 40 Min. rechnen.
Wir müssen ganz langsam gehen.
Denn es gibt viele Löcher
und die Steine sind scharfkantig.
Nicht, dass du dir
das Schienbein total zerschlägst.
Der Gletscher
ist anfangs etwas unruhig.
Er ist wie ein Wellblech
mit Löchern.
Am Ende wird es relativ steil.
Dann hat es auch wieder Schnee.
Bis dorthin ist es blank.
Der Hohlaubgrat selbst
ist ein Firngrat.
Dort ist es also trotzdem steil.
Es ist v.a. nach rechts abschüssig.
Man kann nicht so weit
nach unten blicken,
aber man hat trotzdem
einen gewissen Tiefblick.
Wenn es blank ist,
muss man Eisschrauben setzen.
Dort, wo die Kletterstelle beginnt,
ist es cool -
anfangs ist es steil
und es gibt ein Fixseil.
Dort muss man sich
etwas durchbeissen.
Aber ich glaube,
dieses steile Gelände
ist für dich kein Thema.
Dort sind wir nahezu gleich schnell
wie eine sehende Seilschaft.
Da das Wetter
gegen Mittag eher schlechter wird
und der Wind zunimmt,
stehen wir um 3 Uhr auf.
Also, Frühstück um 3 Uhr
und früher aufstehen.
Hoppla. Okay, gut.
Jede Stunde, die wir gewinnen,
ist praktisch.
Wir müssen nicht hetzen,
aber wir müssen dranbleiben.
Aber wenn wir
4 Std. länger brauchen,
müssen wir uns fragen,
ob wir abbrechen wollen.
Gibt es etwas,
was dich besonders stresst?
Es ist eine lange Tour.
- Die Länge.
Aber damit musste man ja rechnen.
Du sagtest, bis 8 Std. seien okay.
- Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube,
in 10 Std. schaffen wir es.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Morgens um 3.30 Uhr kontrolliert Ralf
als Erstes das Wetter.
Die Gipfel sind auf unserer Höhe
nicht in den Wolken.
Dann machen wir uns auf den Weg.
Das Radar sagt, dass es
bis 11 oder 12 Uhr trocken bleibt.
Es gibt vereinzelte Flecken,
aber das ist noch nicht sicher.
Also, du startest mit Delia,
nicht wahr?
Es windet schon frühmorgens.
In 7 Std. - vor der Wetterfront -
will er auf dem Gipfel sein.
Ein bisschen runter, sorry.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Im Süden gibt es ein Wetterleuchten.
Man sieht die Silhouette der Berge,
dahinter ist es dunkel
und man sieht, wie es blitzt.
Ui!
- Es hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Drüben im Berner Oberland?
- Nein, nein, in Richtung Italien.
Was dort drüben ist,
kommt nicht zu uns.
Was zu uns kommt,
sieht man noch nicht.
Du darfst dein Gewicht
wirklich darauf verlagern.
Ich versuche hier zu gehen.
- Ich muss dich eher so halten.
Die Hand?
- Mhm.
Etwas nach rechts.
Ich habe einen Weg vorbereitet.
Ralf hat bereits
am Vorabend Steinmännchen gesetzt,
um sich zu orientieren,
damit sie im Blockfeld,
das für Laila schwierig ist,
nicht zu viel Zeit verlieren.
Du musst dich nicht beeilen.
Wir haben bald die Hälfte geschafft.
Genau.
Oh!
- Das war genau die Stelle.
Ich halte dich, komm.
Bravo, ihr beiden.
- Ankunft auf dem Gletscher.
Jetzt ist mir warm.
Delia muss nicht ans Seil.
Man kann nicht in den Spalt fallen,
da es blank ist.
Vielleicht zeigt dir das Seil
ein bisschen die Richtung.
Wo du stehst, ist egal.
- Ah, dann kann ich dem Seil folgen.
Ralf versucht es
zuerst ohne Steigeisen,
da Laila so besseren Kontakt
zum Boden und Unebenheiten hat.
Aber es ist rutschig.
Es sieht aus,
als bräuchten wir Steigeisen.
Doch es ist zu rutschig.
* Der Wind übertönt ihre Worte. *
Das Blockfeld, über das ich gestern
Horrorgeschichten erzählte,
haben die beiden super gemeistert.
Die Überquerung war viel leichter,
als ich dachte.
Aber das Wetterleuchten im Süden
gibt einem einen Wink.
Bei uns käme ein Gewitter
eher aus dem Westen.
Dorthin können wir nicht blicken,
da der Gipfel im Weg ist.
Ich bleibe auf jeden Fall achtsam.
* Knirschen der Steigeisen,
Wasserplätschern *
Wir können einen Stein runterwerfen.
Ich habe einen grossen, schau.- Ja.
Wow.- Ich weiss nicht,
ob er schon unten war.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Kann ich losgehen?
- Ja, alles okay.
Du kannst
einen langen Schritt machen.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge,
Pfeifen des Windes *
Es ist 6 Uhr.
Über dem zerklüfteten
Hohlaubgletscher hat -
wie erwartet - der Wind zugelegt.
Habt ihr eure Mützen griffbereit?
- Ja, die Kapuze.
Wenn wir oben sind, ist es etwas
ungemütlich, wenn man suchen muss.
Laila ist noch fit, nicht wahr?
- Mhm.
Du hast noch nicht genug.
Wir gehen noch ein Stück.
Jetzt ist es fast am schlechtesten.
Immer wieder
kontrolliert Ralf das Wetter.
Ab 10 Uhr
wird es wieder etwas schlechter.
Es heisst, in 1 Std. - um 7.30 Uhr -
müssten die Wolken weg sein.
Laila nimmt zur Sicherheit
ein Glöckchen hervor.
Mit dem Wind wird die Kommunikation
immer schwieriger werden.
Von nun an soll ihr
der Klang des Glöckchens,
das Ralf auf sich trägt,
helfen, sich besser zu orientieren.
* Glöckchenklingeln *
Wenn wir oben sind, ist es auf
jeden Fall eine Herausforderung ...
... zu kommunizieren?
Ja, und wir können nicht mehr
so leicht Pausen machen.
Ich denke, die nächsten 10 Min.
werden etwas unangenehm.
Jetzt wird es alpin.
* Glöckchenklingeln *
Die Temperaturen
sind hoch für diese Jahreszeit.
Es gibt wenige Schneebrücken,
dafür mehr Spalten.
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
Gut.
Gut, ja.
Je grösser die Distanz zu Ralf,
desto mehr ist Laila
auf das Glöckchen angewiesen.
Sorry.
(Ausser Atem) Ralf, ähm ...
... kannst du das Glöckchen
so halten, dass es klingelt?
Jawohl.
* Glöckchenklingeln *
Ich mache eine Spur.
Ich schiebe den Schnee
etwas nach rechts.
Noch geht Laila an Stöcken,
die ihr Halt geben.
* Glöckchenklingeln *
Jawohl.
Jetzt wird es nochmals kurz steil.
Dann bist du oben.
Links von dir ist ein Spalt.
Noch einen Schritt nach vorn.
Dort kannst du gut stehen.
Mach einen grösseren Schritt
direkt zu mir.
Mit dem rechten Fuss etwas nach vorn
und mit dem linken nach oben.
Genau.
Hier?
- Ja, das ist super.
Dann gleich wieder
schräg rechts rüber.
Jetzt ist es super.
Auf 3'600 m taucht vor ihnen
auf der linken Seite
ein markantes Blockfeld auf,
über das der Normalweg führt.
Aber Ralf spürt, dass Laila
auf den Steigeisen gut unterwegs ist
und ihre Kräfte einteilen muss.
Das ist der Sauerstoffmangel.
Ich spüre die Höhe ein bisschen.
Manchmal habe ich solche Phasen,
aber das vergeht wieder.
Ich habe einen Plan B:
Du sagtest, mit den Frontzacken
hätte es nicht schlecht geklappt.
Ja, aber es braucht
ziemlich viel Energie.
Wir könnten dem Geröll ausweichen,
wenn wir 30 m mit Frontzacken
klettern würden.
Man erspart sehr viel ein.
Ich nehme das Seil, gehe voran und
sichere es oben mit der Eisschraube.
He, nein.
Er rennt rasch hoch.
* Sie lacht. *
So geil.
Okay, Laila.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Wenn man schon
auf allen Vieren klettern kann ...
Ja, klettere nur auf allen Vieren.
Danach kannst du stehen bleiben.
Moment.
Es ist nochmals die gleiche Strecke,
aber oben liegt etwas Schnee.
Super.
Auch wenn es etwas wild aussieht,
war es gut,
dass wir
das Geröll umgehen konnten.
Laila hat bestimmt
weniger Energie verbraucht.
Definitiv.
Hier kannst du stehen bleiben.
- Was ist hier?
Ein Fels.
- Ist das der Grat?
Fast.
Laila spürt nur,
dass es steil aufwärtsgeht.
Im Gegensatz zu den Sehenden
hat sie keinen Horizont,
an dem sie sich orientieren kann,
und weiss nicht, wie weit es
bis zum Grat ist, den sie erwartet.
Die Informationen von Ralf und Delia
werden immer wichtiger,
damit Laila
ihre Kräfte einteilen kann.
Ralf behält
die Schlechtwetterfront im Auge.
Ab 11 Uhr
soll es Niederschlag geben.
Aber wir sind gut unterwegs.
Schnee oder Regen?
Eher Schnee.
Es gibt Schlimmeres.
Ralf zieht immer weiter,
um keine Zeit zu verlieren.
Auf 3'700 m macht er
nochmals eine kurze Pause,
damit alle Kräfte tanken können.
* Pfeifen des Windes *
Das Wetter ist nicht so gut,
dass wir es
total entspannt angehen könnten.
Es ist gut,
dass wir dem Zeitplan voraus sind.
Wären wir hinter dem Zeitplan,
müssten wir
über einen Abbruch nachdenken.
Aber ich denke,
wenn es so weitergeht,
sind wir in 2 Std. auf dem Gipfel.
Dann liegen wir so gut in der Zeit,
dass wir vor dem schlechten Wetter
wieder unten sind.
Aha.
Sauerstoffmangel.
Man benötigt einfach
für alles mehr Energie.
Etwas nach links.
Der Hohlaubgrat - für Laila, die
nichts sieht, eine Schlüsselstelle.
Das Tempo ist gut.
Auf beiden Seiten
fällt der Grat 400-600 m ab.
* Spannungsvolle Trommelklänge *
Hier ist es etwas uneben.
Kannst du dich
etwas nach links bewegen?
Hier
hast du einen relativ guten Stand.
Bravo.
Wir sind bei den Felsen.
Endlich können wir mal klettern.
Auf 3'900 m erreichen sie
eine rund 100 m hohe Felspassage.
Laila ist inzwischen am Limit.
Ich hoffe, dass ich ...
... mental etwas abschalten kann.
Es war schon ziemlich
bissig bis hier hoch.
Vielleicht ist es auch die Höhe,
die das Limit vorgibt.
Fällt er dir nicht auf den Kopf?
- Nein, nein.
Hier vor dir.
Eigentlich ist das Klettern
Lailas Stärke,
bei der sie alle Sinne nutzen kann.
Du kannst die Kette auch mit beiden
Händen halten und dich hochziehen.
Ja, genau.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Doch durch die Steigeisen
fehlt ihr auf dem Fels
jegliche Referenz
zur Struktur des Felses.
Dort ist ein Eisenring.
Sie muss sich mit den Händen
orientieren, um die Tritte zu finden.
Ralf und Delia geben Sicherheit.
Jawohl.
Wenn du noch einen Schritt
hochsteigst, ist oben die Kette.
Ja, jetzt bist du drin. Gut.
Nicht zu hoch.
Versuch, den Fuss zu wechseln.
Jawohl.
Ja, genau. Vor dir ist ein Plateau.
Ja, dorthin treten. Das ist super.
Gut, sauber.
- Cool.
Ich höre den Wind.
* Pfeifen des Windes *
* Anschwellende epische Musik *
Jawohl.
Laila, du kannst noch ein paar Meter
den Fels hochkraxeln.
Das sind wie Treppenstufen.
* Triumphierende Musik, Jubel *
Hey, Gratulation. Super.
Megacool.
Laila hat es geschafft:
Gemeinsam mit Ralf und Delia
kann sie sich ihren Traum erfüllen.
Dank einem Team,
das sich blind vertraut.
Ich freue mich total,
dass wir es geschafft haben.
Ich würde sagen:
mit vereinten Kräften zum Ziel.
Warst du noch nicht am Limit?
- Doch.
Ich merke, dass ich ziemlich ...
... kaputt bin.
Ja.
Abenteuer pur.
So cool, oh mein Gott.
Wir haben unsere Sache
alle total gut gemacht.
Wirklich cool.
- Ja, schön.
Oh mein Gott, Laila,
ich bin so stolz auf dich.
Du hast das so toll gemacht.
Und so schaffen sie
noch vor dem schlechten Wetter
auch gemeinsam den zweistündigen
Abstieg auf einem Gletscherpfad,
der für Laila leicht zu begehen ist.
Das sehen Sie in der nächsten Folge:
In der Eigernordwand
wollen drei Extrembergsteiger
eine neue Route eröffnen - in
Erinnerung an verstorbene Freunde.
Die Linie, die wir aussuchten,
ist in einem unbekannten Wandteil.
Daher wird es sehr spannend.
Wir erwarten hohe Schwierigkeiten.
Doch sie stossen
auf unerwartete Hindernisse.
Scheisse, jetzt hat mir gerade
einer von da oben,
einer dieser Klassikbegeher,
einen Eisbrocken
auf den Kopf fallen lassen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023